curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video
all right let's start with some
international news today i was not
initially going to talk about this today
but i got emails about it over the
weekend and read a bunch of articles
this morning and there's really like a
bigger story here in what's going on in
europe globally
or the impact of the global impact of
what we start to see in europe and
germany you know we've had this
backstory ever since the election of
donald trump about german chancellor
angela merkel becoming effectively the
leader of the free world now as many uh
uh as i should mention every time i talk
about this that's not an actual position
it's sort of a colloquial designation
often assigned to the president of the
united states
when donald trump was elected it was so
humiliating he was so pathetic that the
consensus we could say
uh plurality of the consensus was that
angela merkel had become the leader of
the free world long-standing german
chancellor we then more recently learned
that she would not be up for re-election
um and we now are
sort of looking to germany in a sense as
a referendum on this authoritarian
rightward shift that we've seen in much
of europe and around the world of course
in places like hungary and others in
europe but also the duterte
style stuff
putin um uh as well as um you know
bolsonaro etc so we are starting to get
uh news from germany and it's actually
looking very very interesting for social
democracy german social democrats beat
conservatives in vote to decide merkel
successor social democrats spd ahead in
projected results spd's schultz claims
clear mandate for pragmatic government
but conservative lache also vows to seek
coalition as i mentioned chancellor
chancellor angela merkel not seeking a
fifth term
germany this is from reuters germany's
social democrats narrowly won sunday's
national election projected results
showed and claimed a quote clear mandate
to lead a government for the first time
since 20 2005 and to end 16 years of
conservative-led rule under angela
merkel now i wouldn't criticize you
if you wrongly thought that angela
merkel was
a centrist or on the left there's no
question that compared to american right
wing nuts merkel seems quite moderate
but by european standards by german
standards merkel was and is a
conservative and this would be a decided
shift uh the center-left social
democrats were on track for 26 of the
vote ahead of the 24 and a half percent
for merkel's cdu csu conservative bloc
both groups believed they could lead the
next government
with neither major block commanding a
majority and both reluctant to repeat
their awkward grand coalition of the
past four years the most likely outcome
is a three-way alliance led by either
the social democrats or merkel's
conservatives so we don't yet know the
answers to who will actually be
in charge there agreeing a new coalition
could take months and will likely
involve the smaller greens and liberal
free democrats social democrats
chancellor candidate olaf schultz says
we are ahead in all the surveys now
um adding it is an encouraging message
and a clear mandate to make sure that we
get a good pragmatic government for
germany
the spd's rise heralds a swing left for
germany and marks a comeback for the
party which has recovered some 10 points
in support in just three months to
improve on its 20 and a half percent
from the 2017 election we don't yet know
what this portends bigger picture for
europe we just don't
but if we are hoping that the
authoritarian right wing slide of the
2012 to 2018 and 19 phase
is going to be pulled back against that
we're going to go back in the opposite
direction
certainly this is
something of an auspicious sign
now whether other countries go in the
same direction
and whether there will be any actual
progress made in germany if indeed olaf
schultz ends up being the chancellor
very very much remains to be seen but
what we're hoping for and again we're
putting these things together without
actually knowing whether they are
related as part of some bigger package
of change
if we continue to see these humiliations
in the u.s for the right the humiliation
in california with the recall
uh trump regularly being humiliated you
know we we've been talking about these
things if we start to see this push in
the other direction
uh and we also start to see a rejection
of the rising far-right nationalism
in europe of which merkel was not a part
but still going merkel to social
democrats would be a good sign
we may enter what some have been hoping
to be
a new progressive era
100 years later remember the progressive
era in the united states
started at the very end of the 19th
century and went into the 20s we've
talked about that really important
historical period before
and of course our my hope as a social
democrat is that we would be soon
entering a new progressive era could all
of these little data points be starting
to signal in that direction uh maybe
maybe remains to be seen one other
article i wanted to look at
cnn reporting spd narrowly wins german
election against merkel's cdu but
uncertainty remains over left
over next leader
germany's left-leaning spd will begin
negotiations to form a ruling coalition
after preliminary results showed the
party narrowly winning the largest share
of parliamentary seats following
sunday's federal election
with all 299 of the electoral districts
reporting spd won 25.7 percent of the
vote beating out the christian
democratic union the centrist right
conservative party of outgoing
chancellor angela merkel which posted
record losses by taking just
24.1 percent but uncertainty over who
the next leader will be
one other thought on merkel um again
because so many see her is basically
center left
in the u.s we're so used to seeing
these right wingers be anti-science
coming from the world of
business or law
being
governing very much with their religion
in play
what i think maybe
led some americans to see merkel as more
center-left
is that her background as a scientist
and her
relatively consistent record of keeping
religion out of governance to some
degree although we could debate that it
doesn't feel like the right winger-ism
that we've become accustomed to in the
united states um and so that's why
relative you know you look at someone
like louis gomer you know or marjorie
taylor green and then you see merkel
merkel seems left wing compared to them
i understand that but merkel part of the
cdu
certainly no uh not not a left-wing
party
good signs from these early results in
germany we're going to continue
following what sort of coalition gets
put together and also whether this is a
sign of things to come in other european
countries
a bunch of people have asked me to
comment
about an article written by cnn's brian
stelter yesterday
and
stelter is not a guy that i particularly
follow
but sometimes he says interesting things
and i think that this is really an
interesting article
the idea here of what brian stelter is
arguing is that these new unhinged
appearances and interviews and rallies
that donald trump is doing
are a sign of some kind of big storm
brewing again that there's multiple
factors here and that there could be
some kind of perfect storm in a sense
between trump and trump's followers in
the republican party and other just
opportunists in the republican party
let's take a look at a little bit of the
article stelter writes i watched donald
trump's entire interview with one
american news propagandist dan ball
and the quote that stood out the most is
our country will not survive this trump
was in the middle of a fact-free rant
about vicious democrats cheating on
elections when he said they're
destroying our country our country will
not survive this our country will not
survive then he sniffed and shifted to
immigration saying look where they're
coming from clearly mimicking the great
replacement theory
that tucker carlson has been mainlining
into homes across the country
these are all signs of the gathering
storm trump's incessant lies about the
last election biden didn't get 81
million votes there's no way pose
obvious threats to future elections the
so-called stop the steel movement is
racing forward ignoring the arizona
audit humiliation
most of us can feel the instability in
the air the same way a forecaster can
feel a storm coming on news outlets need
to be providing storm warnings but some
are ignoring the threat
that's what okay so he talks about his
opening essay uh
he points so so far this is pretty good
stelter also points out that the
right-wing media with few exceptions is
a safe space for the big lie
that's according to timothy snyder
that's absolutely true there has not
been a real concerted effort other than
the minimum needed to avoid legal
problems to say
biden won
that's it
all of this other stuff is not true
stuff about voting machines stuff about
bamboo fibers and barbecue sauces and
various dressings on on ballots and the
ballads being cured or sauteed or smoked
you know i'm exaggerating but none of
this stuff is even there's no evidence
for any of this stuff
um
going on to talk about does brian
stelter
liz cheney says
many of her colleagues in the republican
party privately agree with her privately
agree with her that this election lie
stuff just looks very bad for
republicans the idea being
these republicans are
going along with this stuff even though
they don't believe it at all
and then the big picture according to
stelter is that democracy is in the
midst of a grave recession and points to
hungary poland and venezuela countries
that are no longer really democratic
although they purportedly hold elections
so
i think that there's there's a
you know
i don't find stelter's writing to be
particularly compelling and i don't find
his commentaries to be particularly
interesting but i do think that he's
pointing to some broader truth that
can't be denied at least as a
possibility
trump himself is a narcissist to the
absolute highest degree
the election loss hurt him in a way
that a non-narcissist can barely
understand i've been reading about it to
try to understand how trump gets to this
point where he does the things he's been
doing but it's hard for non-narcissists
to really understand what's going on in
trump's brain
and in addition the idea of people not
paying attention to trump
is very very uh scary to him as a
narcissist that's trump
on the follower side
you have
really low information
radicalized trumpists that are in a
sense enamored with trump as this
narcissistic egomaniac
i don't think we're exaggerating if we
say
many of them are willing to die would be
willing to die for trump would be
uh not that that's going to be a
situation that presents itself for
99.999 of them although i mean you know
look at january 6th it's not it's not
merely hyperbolic or theoretical to say
a trumpus might die for trump in some
sense
so you put all of this together and then
you combine it with a republican party
that even if we grant adam kinzinger has
said it liz cheney has said it a couple
of them have said privately
almost nobody agrees with this stuff
like kinzinger i think said there's a
couple people in my mind i'm thinking he
was talking about marjorie taylor green
or whoever else
if they are right
what that means is it's not that we say
well at least the republican party is
sane because behind the scenes they
don't believe the stuff no no no no
they're the worst class of political
opportunists we can imagine because
behind the scenes they don't believe it
and yet they allow all of this stuff to
continue and in some cases they actually
signal boost it and help it continue
that combination narcissistic trump
uh enamored
egomaniac low information trump
supporters who will do whatever he says
and fall for whatever and then a
republican party that whatever they
believe privately isn't getting in the
way of what donald trump is doing
that is a very disturbing situation and
you could
see circumstances in which if they do
well in 22
if they take the house they're almost
certainly impeaching joe biden without
question it won't he won't get convicted
in the senate but almost certainly and
it may be the exact boost to what we are
hoping is a dying movement in trumpism
doing well in 22 could be the exact type
of boost that will make 23 to 25 the
pure that that legislative session
crazier than even what was going on
under obama when they 63 what was it 64
63 times
voted
to uh eliminate obamacare when they had
the house and obama was president we
said what a waste of time this is crazy
that will be nothing compared to what we
will see from january of 23 to january
of 25
if they take the house partially because
of what they'll do but partially because
of the energy boost it will give to
people like trump and others who will be
thinking about 2024. so stelter's pretty
spot on here i don't know that i would
tell the story the way he tells it i
think i would look at maybe some other
indicators
but there very well may be a storm
brewing and these are the exact worst
people that we would want
running the weather satellites so to
speak when that storm is brewing agree
with me disagree with me let me know you
can find me on twitter at deepakman
one of our sponsors is curiositystream
the only subscription streaming service
that focuses exclusively on
documentaries if you love documentaries
the way i do you're missing out if you
don't have a subscription to curiosity
stream i love it for one reason it has
the biggest best selection of
documentaries that you'll find anywhere
including the newest popular ones that
everybody's talking about and most of it
is stuff you really can't find on other
streaming services last month they added
a ton of great new documentaries to the
library one i watched is brimstone and
glory
about a pyrotechnic festival in mexico
random but fascinating curiosity stream
is giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
remember the david pakman show is
primarily made possible by people like
you people who sign up at joinpakman.com
we do a daily show every day just for
our members the bonus show you can get
instant access by signing up on the
website and you you can use the coupon
code dystopian rally today to get a huge
discount what am i talking about well
donald trump actually held a rally in
georgia on saturday we did a live stream
on youtube twitch and facebook
and he actually sort of had some new
material for once you know these these
trump rallies have been the exact same
material for a very long time communists
and marxists are taking over the country
is ruined unless you elect me unless you
re-elect me unless you put me back in
office as the sort of shifting narrative
has been um no one's making money
anymore you know under biden you'll have
to flush toilets 10 to 15 times hillary
did bad stuff the crowd chanting lock
her up like a time machine back to the
year 2015 so it was a lot of repetition
but
he decidedly and notably added
um that we need to take our country back
by winning in 2022.
we predicted this you predicted this we
we all predicted this
when we wondered
how long is this going to go on right in
december the supreme court will say it
was actually trump who won
it'll be overturned in january and then
january became march which became april
or august or you know whatever
we knew
that eventually it would be well the
midterms are coming up and the way to
take it back is just to win in 2022.
that shift seems to have started and we
saw donald trump on saturday start to
focus on the midterms in addition to
calling joe biden a son of a [ __ ] okay
we're gonna get to that that yes a
former president calling a current
president a son of a [ __ ] it was
deranged it was loony it was humiliating
it was pathetic
but this is a political movement with
power at least for right now and they
are shifting to 2022
and they could win
in 2022 trump praised the border patrol
agents seen whipping haitian migrants
with horse reigns remember they said
they weren't whips so they weren't being
whipped well you could whip someone with
a horse reign and that's what they did
this is the exact type of rhetoric that
fueled the el paso shooter during
trump's presidency take a look
tens of thousands of illegal immigrants
have overrun our borders in recent days
while laughing in the faces of our
border patrol agents
and they're going after the riders of
the horses not the people that came in
illegally isn't that incredible
and they've just put them under watch
they're in big trouble the riders of
those horses
most people would say they were doing
one hell of a job right don't you think
they're in trouble can you believe it so
ramping up the red meat the crowd tuning
in and out as they often do during these
rallies
but really loving that type of stuff and
then trump going very quickly
into 2022 this is the new thing starting
to talk about 2022 and pelosi and more
this is the shift we predicted this is
the shift we've been waiting for it's
happening now georgia is going to be a
central battleground in our fight to
rescue
our beloved nation
you have great great people running many
of them are right here hello margaery
with your help we're going to take back
the house and send nancy pelosi back to
san francisco
where she can work very hard to bring
back a city which she has helped to very
much destroy just like they're
destroying our nation they're destroying
our nation
we're going to fire your ultra left-wing
senator ralph warnock and elect the
great herschel walker to the united
states senate
and we're going to take back our country
from these lunatics
now of course the question really should
be
what happened to getting back in right
the lawsuits the fundraising it was
going to be december january march april
that's just gone i guess it is
predictably so
but no questions being asked about what
happened to all of that taking it back
now stuff now you might have thought
now that the arizona audit showed that
joe biden actually won arizona by even
more than originally reported
that donald trump would ease up on the
voter fraud stuff but no trump never
does that trump never said i joked with
the live audience guys do you think
trump is going to say hey we got the
real arizona audit results and it turns
out biden did win i was wrong sorry
about that i was wrong biden did win of
course not of course not and trump
doubled down and he actually floated the
idea without any evidence whatsoever
that maybe barack obama didn't really
win in 2012. and most presidents go down
in the second term even if they win they
go down obama went down way down
but he won or i don't know maybe he won
who the hell knows everyone
nowadays with these elections who knows
if he won but he went down a lot
and he won so of course there's no
evidence of that
but this is the game if you're not sure
who won 2012 as a republican
then maybe donald trump really did win
in 2020.
that's kind of like the base level game
that's being played here and sadly it
has worked to capture the minds of tens
of millions of these trumpists and
unfortunately you know uh sam harris
actually had a very good piece he got a
um a question from a viewer about hey
why don't you have on like brett
weinstein and some of these people
talking about ivermectin and all this
stuff and and debate them and sam made a
really interesting point whatever you
think about sam harris's politics he
said the problem with these debates
where you have like a contrarian
is that at any time they can say but
what about x
x could be anything and if you don't
know about x to a lot of these folks
that have fallen for the big lie it
comes off as whoa
you're not ready to rebut x
then the conspiracy theorist must be
right and this is why as trump went
further and further into stuff and said
hey you know there were 5 000 people
uh about whom there was no record for
example which is like really vague
language if you're not immediately ready
with an answer the types of folks that
go to these rallies go
wow
5 000 people with no record that they
were supposed to be voting in that
county i don't even know what that means
but nobody's rebutting it so it furthers
these conspiratorial beliefs so it's
very hard to kind of like put them back
uh in it put put them back in the bottle
for lack of a better term trump even
then mentioned
and this is just red meat right that
he's never actually conceded 2020. now
remember concession is a mere formality
but it's another reminder to fire up the
big lie people and the people who think
maybe trump will come back take a look
sir
a great pollster
so we got 63 million he said sir if you
go up one million votes you can't lose
well we went up 12 million votes and
they say we lost
but there never has been
[Music]
you know there never has been a
concession you do know that right
the crowd including the strategically
placed blacks for trump who were on
stage right behind trump
really reacting to that one as you could
tell the crowd tuning out for large
portions of this but getting pulled back
in by xenophobia getting pulled back in
by the stuff about voter fraud as trump
calls it now in this next clip donald
trump actually admits that he called
brian kemp in georgia after the election
and asked him to do a new election a
so-called special election just because
why not right maybe trump would have won
that one instead of joe biden news
but i said to these young people let me
handle it i was going to show them how
good i am
let me head little calm up i said brian
listen you know you have a big election
integrity problem
in georgia
i hope you can help us out and call a
special election and let's get to the
bottom of it for the good of the country
let's get to the bottom of it for the
good of your state let's go election
integrity what could be better than that
sir i'm sorry i i cannot do that
whoa
now kemp was right you can't just say
i don't know let's do another election
because you don't like the results sir
you you can't do that kemp was right
trump mentions mark zuckerberg from
facebook the crowd starts chanting lock
em up and trump says yeah we we should
look at that officials also took 45
million dollars from facebook's mark
zuckerberg
to fund election-related activities
[Applause]
well they should be looking at that what
what is that all about so completely
dystopian completely authoritarian
i am increasingly convinced that
facebook is a net negative for society
but lock up mark zuckerberg it's the
same type of authoritarian stuff that
they claim to be for law and order and
due process except when it's the trump
rioters subjected to that process they
say oh no no just let them out and you
know whatever uh and then when it's
someone they don't like like mark
zuckerberg just lock them up lock them
up what what crime or is even suspected
of guys
trump also tried claiming that the
arizona so-called audit which remember
it confirmed that joe biden won
actually says trump won it's all lies
take a look
yesterday we also got the results of the
arizona audit
which
which were so disgracefully reported by
those people right back there and the
headlines
claiming that biden won
[Applause]
that biden one are fake news and a very
big lie you know they like to you ever
notice when they write about that they
were saying while the election
results are a big lie even the biased
audit
confirmed that joe biden won and we're
gonna we're gonna talk about that
trump then called
for arizona's 2020 results to be quote
decertified
sir they just confirmed you lost what
are you talking about decertification
the total decertification
it is clear
in arizona
that they must decertify the election
you heard the numbers
and those responsible for wrongdoing
must be held accountable it was a
corrupt election trump is the one
responsible for the wrongdoing and he
should be held accountable without a
doubt uh no trump rally is really
complete without some glitches and uh
short circuiting trump short-circuited
on the word obliterating uh came up with
obliterizing just a little bit of the
flavor and color but joe biden is
obliterated he's just obliterating yeah
and then he also had a doozy of a time
with military installations which
i i guess instantations is the way he
sees them military institutions and
their installations and they have a lot
of things surrounding maybe he meant
instantiation somehow i don't i don't
really think so uh and then the former
president also claiming that people are
finally starting to say merry christmas
so the truth is no one really stopped
this is just that culture war stuff but
he did pull that out out as well that
too much
and you know they are starting to say
very strongly merry christmas remember
when i first ran i said you're going to
say merry christmas they're all saying
merry christmas again
we better move fast because that'll end
also like everything else yeah so again
the the very interesting trend is we've
talked about how the republican party
has been totally devoid of policy for at
least as long as donald trump has been
at the forefront
um
you can tell in the reactions of the
crowd they get bored when trump reads
numbers or when he goes any into
anything that could be considered
remotely policy oriented of which
there's very little it's not even really
policy it's just like lies about the
policies you're ascribing to others the
crowd tunes out they're interested in
xenophobic stuff about it was great that
the migrants were being whipped
they tune into voter fraud stuff
and they tune into the culture war stuff
we will say merry christmas or we've
been saying it thanks to me or whatever
um and then like i said at the top yeah
donald trump referred to joe biden as a
stupid son of a [ __ ] take a look very
hard and they understood that that's why
i told you before 18 months we didn't
have one soldier killed and even biden
said that it was a mistake they said he
said well i will say that no soldiers
have been killed in 18 months and
there's people screaming at him don't
say that you stupid son of a [ __ ]
so again the crowd really loving it just
absolutely loving that so a wild rally
and listen for now
it's clear trump's going to be involved
in 2022 depending on who wins and loses
depending on whether republicans are
seen as being strengthened by the
midterms or further weakened
he will stay involved before that we
don't know yet it remains to be seen but
there's lots and lots of work to do
uh and i do to some degree
um uh uh coincide with the brian stelter
article we looked at earlier i think all
of this together the resurgence of the
rally
the trump interviews
the escalated conspiracy theories being
spread related to the election now that
we're closer i mean listen we're almost
a year out guys i do think there's
something brewing here
it may just be some really
uh
low information way to try to win the
midterms i don't know yet but we're
going to keep following it and we'll
have more on this on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to join
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
all right let's get into some
interesting news items from the weekend
the most interesting and the biggest one
and the one that has the most uh
sort of comical implications is that
they finished the audit in arizona
now
i'm not even sure whether i should be
using the term audit because it wasn't
really an audit but what was being
described as an audit in arizona meant
to uncover
depending on your beliefs that joe biden
didn't really win
and that donald trump really did has
finished and it found not only did joe
biden win he actually won by a larger
margin his margin of victory actually
expanded so let's look at some of the
reporting on this you might think well
this is the end right this is it no they
now want more audits they want another
audit in arizona they want another audit
elsewhere and we'll look at a hilarious
second article which points out the
point of these artists audits is not
exactly clear so associated press
republican review finds no proof arizona
elections stolen from trump
that's we could stop there but the
details are actually even funnier
a republican-backed review of the 2020
presidential election in arizona's
largest county ended friday without
producing proof to support former
president donald trump's false claims of
a stolen election
this is maybe my favorite news paragraph
of the last six months
after six months of searching for
evidence of fraud
the firm hired by republican lawmakers
issued a report that experts described
as riddled with errors
bias and flawed methodology
still
even that partisan review came up with a
vote tally that would not have altered
the outcome finding that biden won by
360 more votes than the official results
certified last year okay
it was biased
it was partisan
it may not even have been an audit
but they came up with a final number and
it's joe biden actually won by 360 more
than what the results were
in november now when you look at the
actual margin
and then you compare it to 360 votes
it's irrelevant okay the article goes on
to say the finding was an embarrassing
end to a widely criticized and at times
bizarre
quest to prove allegations that election
officials and courts have rejected it
has no bearing on the final certified
results previous reviews of the 2.1
million ballots by nonpartisan officials
professionals that followed state law
have found no significant problem with
the vote count in maricopa county home
to phoenix biden won the county by 45
000 votes key to his 10 500 vote win of
arizona this was why they focused on
maricopa because if
maricopa is big enough population wise
that if it was really wrong
it could have flipped the election
results of course there was never a
reason to think that the results were
really wrong for many critics the
conclusions presented at the hearing
friday by the firm cyber ninjas
it's crazy that this is the world we
live in okay cyber ninjas
underscored the futility of the exercise
which has helped fuel skepticism about
the validity of the 2020 election and
spawned copycat audits nationwide now
you might think it's over now
it's not
um there is another article from the
associated press from the day after
these results from saturday explainer as
arizona election audit ends new ones
begin
the most closely watched attempt by
republicans to examine the 2020
presidential election in a battleground
state lost by former president donald
trump is coming to an embarrassing end
in arizona but their efforts are
cranking up elsewhere the most recent is
in texas
we'll talk about this on the bonus show
where the secretary of state's office
announced thursday it would conduct a
full and comprehensive audit forensic
audit
of the 2020 election in four counties
these this is this is my favorite these
reviews go by various names audits or
investigations sometimes with the word
forensic attached but their scope is not
always well defined or understood even
by those pushing them
which is true sometimes you'll talk to
the people involved and they'll say we
don't really know what the mechanism is
where what we would uncover would really
change anything but we're doing it
critics say they really have one goal to
validate trump's baseless claims that
widespread fraud cost him the election
regardless of what the reviews might
find so this is the humiliating end of
the much publicized arizona audit
now
we already talked earlier about at his
rally on saturday if you were waiting
for trump to say hey guys you know what
i asked for an audit they did the audit
turns out joe biden really won if you
were waiting for that if you were
holding your breath for that
you're probably running out of breath
right now of course he didn't do that he
said actually
the
the audit results show i really really
won just the total and total total
complete liar um will summer who has
been a guest on our show has been
covering this and actually tweeted
arizona audit backers have been
distancing themselves for weeks saying
you can't really find fraud in a recount
or as in the case of michael flynn
posting this bizarre letter from we the
people demanding the arizona senate
consider reports from even bigger kooks
than cyber ninjas yeah it was never
going to find anything
there was nothing to find based on the
evidence we had but it was never going
to find anything unless they just
straight up lied so what's next it's
over right no
now they're moving on to texas we'll
talk about that on the bonus show
this is i have to tell you this is just
a hilarious story
rudy giuliani
or giuliani depending on your preference
he apparently has been banned from fox
news
for a while now
there's a rolling stone article
rudy giuliani whines about fox news band
to steve bannon rudy is apparently very
hurt over getting booted from a network
who's facing a 1.6 billion dollar
lawsuit because of the former mayor's
remarks it appears that
this is sort of like an informal ban of
rudy from fox news because the stuff
that he spent months saying on fox news
and other networks
since the election of 2020
have gotten fox news and other media
outlets into a lot of trouble
um during the taping of the war room
podcast on friday bannon asked giuliani
how the network could put him on double
secret probation particularly over 9 11.
um there's no reason to include his son
andrew rudy giuliani said
um let's take a look at the video clip
this is by the way this video is crazy
because rudy talks about being banned
from fox news
but as like a secondary layer of
insanity steve bannon says that
the electors from i guess arizona are
going to be decertified
the electors are not going to be
decertified i don't even know what that
means but then rudy complains about
being banned on fox news like what
bannon says is crazy for its own segment
quite frankly let's take a look rudy
giuliani and look at it now the mock and
ridicule okay they ain't gonna be
mocking and ridiculing when the criminal
referrals come out and also wait for it
decertification these elections and
these electors are gonna be decertified
okay
as sure as the turning of the earth
they're going to be decertified and i
understand up on capitol hill the
democrats don't like that i'm sorry
that's just a fact and every day we're
grinding and we're not backing off rudy
how can fox news put you on double
secret probation
particularly for 9 11 and also include
your son who i think is running for the
governorship in new york how does that
work
i mean
there's no
uh there'd be no reason to include
answers but in any i mean
they do a pretty good separation between
hunter biden and and joe biden
gosh you know it's outrageous but the
fact is
that every single thing that i said
about arizona
is right here so it's really not going
super well for rudy giuliani um this has
become a pretty
sad chapter
but um
giuliani apparently was scheduled to
appear on fox and friends on 9 11 like
this past 9 11
and pete hegseth
who's one of the hosts of fox and
friends called giuliani the night before
to inform him he'd been cut
fox denies this and says rudy wasn't
scheduled to be on the show
fox did not deny that giuliani had been
banned so my reading of this
is
as far as fox and friends knew
rudy was scheduled to be on the show
heg seth called rudy and said you're not
gonna be on anymore
and when fox news says rudy wasn't
scheduled to be on all that might mean
is rudy's not allowed on at all so he
couldn't possibly have been scheduled
because he's not allowed on the show but
at the show level fox and friends might
have been planning or hoping to have
rudy on very sad chapter in rudy's
political career a very long chapter
this entire trump chapter is getting
pretty long would make for a pretty
interesting documentary a sort of tragic
comedy the farting at the fraud events
the leaking hair dye while lying about
the election like every
policy or more substantive related
failure
is uh alongside
some other type of failure like the
farting or
uh the leaking hair dye or whatever the
case may be they do not want rudy
exposing them to more legal liability on
fox news i think it's that simple as far
as why he hasn't been there um and what
rudy giuliani's next chapter is is
anyone's guess but rudy apparently
banned from fox news and the the sort of
bigger picture story
that we've been seeing is
there is now this growing
uh
piece of the right wing
that is too crazy for fox news and this
applies both to guests and to viewers so
fox has said no rudy giuliani for now
reportedly there's also a large
contingent of trumpists who say fox is
now on the left no more fox we it's
newsmax it's oan
it's steve bannon's war room or whatever
whatever the case may be
this is a further radicalization of the
right which we talked about earlier and
i won't spend more time on before
now but a very important part of what's
going on here
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow so i've got
a couple of pretty horrible um covid
related stories sadly these aren't fun
stories these aren't stories to make fun
of people these are really stories that
are uh pitiable stories
but also just another indictment of the
completely backward situation we have in
this country with who people or at least
who some people are willing to trust
when it comes to medical advice and the
way propaganda spreads and
disinformation so let's start with the
first one
new mexico health officials suspect two
people dead from ivermectin poisoning
symbol that's usa today similarly kob
reporting two new mexicans have died of
ivermectin toxicity per state health
officials state health leaders say more
people are taking ivermectin to treat
covid19 in some cases it's been deadly
the new mexico department of health said
two people in new mexico have died from
ivermectin toxicity not much is known
about either patient but one of them was
battling a severe case of covid19 it's a
serious issue we need to watch it says
dr david skrace
acting secretary of the new mexico
department of health
new mexico health leaders are sounding
the alarm on ivermectin poison control
said there have been 20 exposures to the
drug this year alone already double the
usual amount
we've had cases of seizures
hallucinations coma you know it can be
very dangerous if you take a high enough
dose
officials say the majority of the
exposures were in the past few weeks
most to treat or prevent covid health
experts say the data just isn't there to
prove it works our medical advisory team
has looked at this three times still
does not feel people should be taking it
and of course the fda has not yet
approved it um ivermectin is almost
exclusively used to treat parasites in
horses and cattle in rare instances
humans same drug different formulation
different dose if you take too much you
go into a coma you may have seizures you
may have hallucinations it's a it's
basically a neurological toxin recent
studies have shown it has some effect on
covid but at a pretty significant cost
when it was combined with standard
therapy it had lower death rate and
progression to severe disease but in
that in vitro study you needed clearly
toxic doses to achieve the effect on
virus replication i think that's an
important detail to mention here we had
that call from a uh biomedical
researcher a couple weeks ago who said
you know you have to understand that
when a study says that in vitro
it kills covid uh particles deactivates
covet whatever term you want to apply
there
in vitro and in vivo are two different
things but the relative dose of what you
can do in vitro
could be completely toxic in humans and
where i continue to go back
is it's really strange to me
not to take something tested
given to billions
and fda approved the pfizer vaccine
and instead take ivermectin i i just
don't get it like even if it's true that
it might be slightly effective for covid
if it's in addition to all the standard
stuff but it can have real side effects
which is dubious but let's imagine
that's the case
um
why accept the cost when we have a
vaccine that is
more effective and i don't know that
we're necessarily going to get an answer
to that right now
the usa today article adding a few other
details
um that i wanted to mention
um
the confirmation comes week weeks after
the state suspected one person was
fatally poisoned by ivermectin the
anti-parasitic drug has not been
approved for treatment of viral
illnesses
uh such as covet 19 but has attracted
popular advocacy particularly among
skeptics of the vaccines treatments and
public health measures such as masking
in public including popular podcaster
joe rogan the fda warned people against
taking it
skrace the director of new mexico's
department of health has previously
expressed concern about pseudoscientific
messaging about the drug which is
approved for human and vet use against
unrelated conditions the state's poison
control center reported last week calls
related to ivermectin tripled compared
to 2020
different than the than the previous
report of doubling that i mentioned
um
veterinary this is also an important
detail veteran veterinary formulations
are not approved for human use under any
conditions because the drug is often
highly concentrated for animals and the
medications include ingredients not
approved for human use so that's
ivermectin in new mexico
next
we have a new one now
hydrogen peroxide vapor yes
so
we've talked about ivermectin
we've talked about people using iodine
sometimes sold under i guess it's like
the trade name betadine
and now we have to talk about inhaling
hydrogen peroxide vapor
an article on health.com
titled no
inhaling hydrogen peroxide vapor to cure
cove it won't work
doctors warn please do not do this
the covet-19 pandemic has brought
questionable treatments it mentions
ivermectin
others are now reportedly inhaling
hydrogen peroxide
the asthma and allergy foundation of
america released a warning this week
urging people not to try this dangerous
treatment trend that's making the rounds
on social media
some users claim that putting hydrogen
peroxide into a nebulizer that's a
breathing machine that turns liquid
asthma medication into a mist and then
breathing in the mist will help cure
covet 19.
many social media sites are flagging and
yanking videos and claims but
screenshots are still showing up someone
named ryan graney posted friends
our vaccines will no longer be valid on
october 20th what and ivormectin will
reign supreme they are going to burn
their damn lungs off three percent food
grade hydrogen peroxide in a nebulizer
or a small syringe you can squirt it in
your nose add saline to it if it's too
harsh
the facebook post from a naturopathic
doctor
suggests putting hydrogen peroxide in a
nebulizer for lung issues someone named
dr becky campbell
puts this is not medical advice but
did you know you can put colloidal
silver
and even hydrogen peroxide in a
nebulizer it can help your body fight
off pathogens systemically and can be
very effective
this is another dangerous unproven idea
and we have
a proven approved vaccine
okay
the aafa is practically begging people
to pass on this do not put hydrogen
peroxide into your nebulizer and breathe
it in this is dangerous it is not a way
to prevent nor treat covet
it is unclear where this originated
experts agree it's a really bad idea
look at this jamie allen phd associate
professor of pharmacology and toxicology
at michigan state says
hydrogen peroxide is a free radical
meaning it's an unstable atom that can
damage cells
if it's inhaled it goes to the lungs
where it can damage cell membranes it
can even get into the cells once the
cell membranes are compromised and can
damage dna
if you inhale too much you can do major
damage to your lungs you can also
struggle with breathing normally and may
develop fluid in your lungs a condition
known as a pulmonary edema
md scholar at john hopkins
says i'm not even sure why people have
stumbled upon this there's no evidence
it can work to treat covet it can be
dangerous especially if you have
sensitive lungs hydrogen peroxide can
kill covet on surfaces
but inhaling it is a different story
this is basically like trump's hit the
body with an injection of uh
disinfectant right i mean it's okay you
might have a surface and something can
kill covet there
so what about putting it inside the body
as he likes to say doesn't apply doesn't
apply and it doesn't translate and again
part of this is
just
contrarianism what i mean by that is
they say
i don't know what's in the vaccine so
i'm not putting it in my body it hasn't
been studied enough so i'm not putting
it in my body
but then they'll accept unknown or at
least in these contexts unstudied
substances
uh and really what it comes down to is
biden's recommending the vaccine
biden's not recommending hydrogen
peroxide vapor or ivermectin
or betadine iodine and it's
contrarianism because they will accept
unknown or unstudied substances as long
as it's not the one a democrat is
recommending but this is still the issue
of
they want to say you can't tell me what
to do
that's
you know they they claim that the
principles are unstudied don't know
what's in it chemicals etc
really the prince of the principle is
you can't tell me what to do
i'm not going to follow the medical
advice of public health officials or of
doctors but then random people on
facebook like this naturopathic doctor
with an inhaler
nebulizer says hey here's an idea not
medical advice but here's an idea of
something you can do
and that they seem to gladly be
following this is a crisis of education
this is a crisis of critical thinking
and if you are the type of person
um
who may even have compromised lungs
already and would be particularly at
risk by nebulizing hydrogen peroxide
really you should be vaccinated because
you're at risk of more serious covid
that's the bottom line we've said it a
million times i i
how many more times can i really repeat
it uh i i have a feeling it'll probably
be a few more times all right we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p we uh the san antonio troll is
back if anybody was worried that he
wasn't doing well or whatever the case
may be he's fine he's calling back the
san antonio troll is known for
criticizing me
for things i haven't said
let's take a listen
tackling you have had the same voicemail
message for like 10 years now time to
update anyways
i am i you know what i'm 100 for a
vaccine mandate now that includes two
illegals david paxton says damn it he
got me the san antonio forgotten that's
right man when you do something like a
vacuum mandate in your old holier now
liberalism okay
you do not foresee the two-way street
that is i i hope
now everybody is like yeah we mandate
vaccines no matter where you come from
let's do it that means no more legal
pacman
a lot less democrats another [ __ ] you
remember
undocumented immigrants don't vote
because they're not citizens
there's really no i mean what what would
it mean for undocumented immigrants to
vote
each one would need to know of some
registered voter
go to the polling place
and say hey i'm john smith and then the
next person says hey i'm susie whatever
and you'd have to hope you showed up
before the real voter
it's a crazy way to try to steal an
election it it just wouldn't work
there's no evidence it's even been tried
honestly if that were the case if
democrats were consistent on this issue
i would probably devote democrats if
they because now you have democrats like
yourself
and even democrat politicians say oh we
could we could take in tens of millions
from uh
stop and patrol america just bring them
all over unvaccinated but you guys
supposedly care about kelvin but no no
let's do the vaccine mandate then
backwards damn it
got me
it's uh
it's quite the uh quite the predicament
you got yourself in there pacquiao good
luck uh getting yourself out of that one
anyway taking these pacman love yourself
ed does anybody have even the slightest
idea what that caller is talking about
uh it seems to be a combination of
confusion and reacting things that
somebody else must have said it's very
common that this guy calls in and
attacks me for things i haven't said on
today's bonus show
texas has now announced an audit of 20
20 votes in four counties
what's the point trump won texas we'll
talk about it on the bonus show number
two
a federal judge
has blocked a vaccine mandate for new
york city teachers why
and what happens now
and number three on the bonus show what
about 3d printing your own vaccine at
home
and instead of being a shot into the
body as trump says
it's a patch
very interesting new technology that
apparently offers an opportunity for
even more effective immunization
and antibody response all of those
stories and more are on today's bonus
show
get instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com coupon code
dystopian rally all one word all
lowercase dystopian rally
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video